[Music]
hey everybody huge news so we got all
this infinity war stuff that's going on
spider-man's a big part of that we get
to see the new spider-man suit during
that but they're also ramping up on
pre-production of spider-man homecoming
2 and they'll be shooting that next
summer right after they get done
shooting Avengers 4 and their infinity
war press tour so there are two big
things that are happening at the
beginning of the year next year for the
Avengers characters they finished
shooting Avengers 4 sometime in January
confirmed by mr. Winter Soldier
Sebastian Stan thank you very much and
then because the premiere of infinity
war is at the beginning of May their
press tour will start just a little bit
before that then as of right now I
believe the start date for actually
shooting spider-man homecoming 2 is
sometime at the beginning of June so
like right after infinity war premieres
everybody starts rolling camera on that
first spider-man movie that set during
phase 4 Kevin Feige confirmed it's the
very first phase for movie so if you are
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get everything because
there's gonna be so much Marvel stuff
happening for the first half of next
year and that doesn't even include
Deadpool 2 in all the phase 4 movies
like Captain Marvel that they're gonna
be filming next year too but the
hilarious thing that you may have heard
recently is that they confirmed the
working title of spider-man homecoming 2
is the fall of George which is a
reference to the summer of George
Seinfeld episode so I'll explain what
that means but it's also sort of a
continuation of an easter egg from the
first spider-man homecoming movie who's
working titled was literally the summer
of George
so the Marvel and the Sony people that
make the spider-man movies are huge
Seinfeld fans I'll explain why it is
that they picked the Seinfeld episode as
the working title of their movies but
beyond that there's all these gwen stacy
auditions that have been surfacing so it
sounds like we will legit get gwen stacy
and for those of you that are wondering
even though all the kids in the
spider-man homecoming movies are high
school kids a lot of them are characters
that go on to become really big comic
book villains and comic book heroes
eventually it's just that they're all in
high school right now so I'm not
expecting a whole lot of costumes one of
the biggest things in the last couple of
years to take off since they've rebooted
the spy
man movies is that the spider-gwen
character has taken off I don't think
that the movies gonna actually do her I
think it'll just be Kuenn Stacy when she
shows up captain Stacy there's something
that I need to just be brave and tell
you it's well it's okay Gwen I already
know wait so how many oh they just
dropped that trailer for the animated
spider-verse movie with Miles Morales
the people that made that did tease that
there would be multiverse stuff going on
so you would see a lot of other versions
of the Spider characters so I think
that's where they'll put spider-gwen
silk in all the various different
versions of spider-man that you've ever
wanted to see so if you want to see
spider-verse stuff I think they're gonna
keep that largely animated and for the
most part the only version of spider-man
that you will see in the live-action MCU
movies is Tom Holland himself you just
get to see him in a parade of different
costumes so we'll talk about the
changing costume between infinity war
and spider-man homecoming 2 because it's
always possible that he keeps that iron
spider suit after infinity war rewind a
little bit though to explain that
Seinfeld Easter Egg the reason why the
producers used that is the working title
the summer of George is is because when
they were ramping up for pre-production
for the first spider-man homecoming
movie there was a local channel in Los
Angeles that just played nothing but
Seinfeld reruns around the time that
they were meeting with each other just
to talk about how the movie was gonna go
down so every day they would come into
the office talking about Seinfeld
episodes so when it came time to pick a
working title for the movie they were
like what's gonna make us laugh the most
so they decided to go with the Seinfeld
title so when it came time to do
spider-man homecoming - they just went
with fall of George because fall comes
after summer so you get the joke there
it doesn't necessarily imply any plot
but the really cool thing we've been
talking about gwen stacy joining the
movie George Stacy is Captain George
Stacy Gwen Stacy's father so it's
totally possible that that just works
out it could be a coincidence
it could be intentional but it makes
sense that they would introduce some
more of the classic spider-man
characters and even though they have
this long-standing romance in the comics
before he gets to
with mary-jane we all saw the way they
ended things with the Michelle character
at the end of spider-man homecoming and
her real name is Michelle Jones so she's
not Mary Jane Watson but they're calling
her MJ so even though there's not a
whole lot of time for romance
in these big comic book movies they
might have some sort of love triangle
that they briefly joke about during the
film usually it's played for comedy
because these are high school kids there
are a couple big things that they teased
during the spider-man homecoming
post-credits scene that they have to
follow up on this is that on you it's on
our little spider friend I've got some
boys on the outside who would just love
to meet him you know take a picture
slice his throat but his head in a dryer
and I heard a rumor
you know is the idea that the sinister
six is slowly coming together it might
be a little bit early to do them I would
rather if they're gonna do a trilogy of
movies and they reappear sharing
arrangement they push actual sinister
six team up to the third spider-man
homecoming movie and they just introduce
a new member of the sinister six as the
big bad like Kraven the hunter or
Mysterio or even Sandman Sandman doesn't
feel like he's quite as big as Kraven
the hunter though but they haven't
revealed who they're casting as the main
villain yet so on the Avengers side of
things because this is phase four and
they're changing the face of the Marvel
Universe
they also confirm that an a-list Avenger
would be in the movie just like Tony
Stark was in the first spider-man
homecoming movie but they said that it
would be somebody different and they
didn't confirm who that would be I think
they're waiting to see which of those
actors rescind their contracts like if
Chris Evans doesn't want to be Captain
America anymore
but I would really love to see Bruce
Banner Hulk in a spider-man homecoming
movie the reason why they might not use
him even though it would be hilarious
and he would probably have some
chemistry with may in the way that Tony
teased Peter a lot about how good his
aunt look because she was so young but
there are supposed to be so much Hulk in
Avengers 3 in Avengers 4 so I don't know
if they would double down on him right
after that it could be any number of the
Avengers let me know in the comments
which a-list Avenger that we haven't
seen team-up with spider-man
do you want to see in the next
homecoming movie it would be about the
same amount as you saw Iron Man during
spider-man homecoming so above cameo
level but not quite a co-star because
the movies still mostly spider-man Tom
Holland but just remember even though
they're casting Gwen Stacy don't expect
her to be the main focus of the film
because they kind of did that during the
Andrew Garfield era so whatever ends up
happening with the plot I'm still
expecting Zendaya's MJ to be the main
female character and I do think that
she'll figure out the Peter Parker is
spider-man because she's just a little
bit smarter than everyone else and from
what we've seen of him Peter isn't
exactly the world's greatest detective
and not the best Keeper of Secrets his
best friend found out he was spider-man
in like the first 20 minutes of that
movie what
hiding Peter I'm just kidding out okay
bye but for the most part when you're
trying to make predictions about what
they're doing just remember that there
might be a lot of changes in the face of
the MCU after Avengers 4 but for the
most part they will follow up on a lot
of the things that they set up during
spider-man homecoming so the characters
will be back they'll follow up on that
Mac Gargan scorpion post-credits scene
they get hype because this is all coming
after Peters next big Avengers retreat
which is two different movies infinity
war and then whatever they call Avengers
4 which I'm just thinking of as the
Infinity Gauntlet right now there's a
whole bunch more comic-book stuff that's
gonna drop before the end of the year so
leave all your bonus video requests and
there is a new round of that imax ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a spider-man
related comments on the video
congratulations to the winner from my
last video Green Goblin
please private message me so I can get
your contact details there'll be a new
round when I post new Marvel click here
for my new infinity war Spidey pool
video and click here for my Star Wars
the last Jedi Easter eggs thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]